not everyone should code
you don't need to run a scientific study
to know that most people who tried to
learn coding failed miserably
all of these people have something in
common
which made them incapable of becoming
software developers
you will most probably suck in
programming if you have these signs
sign number one
you don't like sitting
if you don't like to spend unlimited
thousands of hours sitting at a desk in
front of a computer monitor all day
programming might not be for you
it's as simple as that
that's what software developers do sit
in front of a computer and develop
software
the basic job function requires you to
be in front of a keyboard writing code
the only good thing here is it's like
playing video games
once you start to enjoy it thousands of
hours of sitting will pass by relatively
quickly
nevertheless if you don't want to sit in
front of a computer you don't want to
become a software developer
sign number two
no interest in solving a puzzle
programming is more like solving puzzles
programming is a combination of your
knowledge of a particular language such
as python c or javascript and how well
you can apply it using your logical
ability
the primary puzzle every programmer has
to solve is to make a computer do a
particular task the world of programming
is very flexible
there are innumerable solutions to each
and every coding problem out there some
more efficient than others
therefore to be an effective software
developer one has to apply their brains
and find the most efficient solution
possible for every coding task at hand
if you do not enjoy this type of brain
intensive work
then you should definitely think if
software development is a right fit for
you
sign number three
no excitement after solving a problem
if you don't feel a sense of excitement
and accomplishment after solving a
problem
you will never be successful as a
programmer
you have to be excited about what you
have been doing and feeling drowsiness
by seeing those black lines in the
command prompt window
after solving a problem no matter if it
is hard or easy if you are not motivated
or excited then sorry programming
probably is not your thing
sign number four
you like repetitive tasks
programmers are really creative
they do not like being repetitive
taskers and if they find some part of
any repetitive task
they write a piece of software to
automate it
so if you prefer repetitive tasks less
mentally taxing that allow you to let
your mind wander and new tasks overwhelm
you in that sense
programming might not be a good place
for you
sign number five
low frustration tolerance
to build a project of significant scope
you have to be the type that isn't
easily defeated
in particular you can't become
frustrated while debugging and give up
on the project
not all smart people have this
personality trait
best computer programmers usually have a
high tolerance for failure
they often have to implement the same
algorithm many times before finding how
to do it correctly
and then after the perfect solution has
been found
they often realize that they need to
redo everything this is called
refactoring
when the program does something wrong
software developers view this as a
challenge rather than a frustration
besides consider this fact
programming takes a while to master and
if you're new to programming there are
many people better than you
if you're used to being the smartest in
the room this can be a humbling and
frustrating experience
sign number six
not a team player and full of ego
programmers try to minimize ego by
emphasizing that they code for the team
and with the team
it's not about you
it's about the team the code the client
the stakeholders and the customers
positive feedback and celebrating
success as a team is also essential
if you have a high ego it is usually
hard to ask for help or accept criticism
from others offering a better coding
solution
if you are not a team player you should
not consider programming as your career
sign number seven
if you want to be told what to do
every program is different
every algorithm is different
the programming landscape changes every
day
faster and faster
there will never be a situation where
someone will be able to tell you what to
do
they will tell you what they need and
you will have to figure out how to do it
on your own
over and over and over again
you sure can have a mentor initially but
in the long run you are on your own
sign number eight
zero patience
programming is like parenting
an idea is being provided or forced on
you
now you need to nurture it no matter how
hard or how complicated it is
you need to find a way to understand it
you want it to be perfect in every way
it can be
and to do that requires a lot of
patience
besides without patience
a person will not spend sufficient time
to study a coding problem and generate
the best possible solution
on top of that you have to love
debugging to be a programmer which
requires a lot of patience as well
to do it effectively you must remain
calm at least common enough to think
straight
if you can't focus your own thoughts on
coding problems with consistent patience
programming is most likely not a good
fit for you
sign number nine
aversion against googling
the programmers who have reached the
level of expertise in the field of
software development are very effective
at using google
stack overflow
github and other online resources to
build a technical knowledge advantage
anyone unwilling to use search engines
for at least an hour each day should not
consider a software developer job
sign number 10
if you have never said
there's got to be a better way
the best software programmers
continuously search for the better way
to accomplish their work
it is the very essence of computer
programming that we are always trying to
find ways to do everything better
if you are not curious enough to search
for a better way then programming is
definitely not for you
if you found this video useful i'd
appreciate it if you smash the like
button and click on the notification
bell
also make sure to subscribe to the
coding tech channel for more videos like
this in the future